En un video anterior hablamos sobre la noción de
equivalencia en ecuaciones, y la equivalencia es
sólo esta noción de que hay diferentes formas de
escribir enunciados equivalentes en álgebra. Y
puedo dar algunos ejemplos sencillos, puedo
decir que 2x = 10 o puedo decir que x = 5,
estas son ecuaciones equivalentes, ¿por qué lo
son? Porque un valor de x satisface a una de
ellas si y sólo si ese valor satisface a la otra,
y puedes verificar que en ambos casos x = 5 es el
único valor de x que satisface a ambas. Otro
conjunto de ecuaciones equivalentes es 2x = 8
y x = 4; estas dos son ecuaciones equivalentes:
un valor de x satisface a una ecuación si y sólo
si satisface a la otra. En este video vamos a
extender nuestro conocimiento de equivalencia para
pensar en sistemas equivalentes, y en realidad,
antes, cuando resolvías sistemas de ecuaciones,
realizabas operaciones suponiendo equivalencia,
pero es posible que no lo hayas pensado de esa
manera. Así que planteemos un sistema, digamos que
este sistema nos dice que existe un par xy donde
2x + y = 8 y que x + y = 5. Ahora podemos tener
un sistema equivalente si reemplazamos cualquiera
de estas ecuaciones con una versión equivalente.
Entonces, por ejemplo, muchos de ustedes, cuando
tratan de resolver esto, podrían decir: "Bien, si
esto fuera un 2x negativo, tal vez podría sumar
el lado izquierdo", y hablaremos de por qué esta
es una operación que mantiene la equivalencia,
pero para obtener un 2 negativo aquí tendrías que
multiplicar esta ecuación entera por 2 negativo.
Entonces, si haces eso, si multiplicas ambos lados
por 2 negativo, lo que obtendrás es 2x negativo
-2 y = 10 negativo. Esta ecuación y esta ecuación
son equivalentes, ¿por qué?, porque cualquier par
xy que satisfaga a una de ellas satisfará a la
otra, o un par xy satisface a una si y sólo si
satisface a la otra. Entonces, si ahora pensamos
en el sistema, este sistema donde reescribí esta
segunda ecuación, y mi primera ecuación es la
misma, es un sistema equivalente a nuestro primer
sistema. Entonces, cualquier par xy que satisface
uno de estos sistemas va a satisfacer al otro y
viceversa. Ahora, la próxima cosa interesante que
podrías darte cuenta, y si sólo estabas tratando
de resolver esto, ojo: este no es un video
introductorio en la resolución de sistemas, estoy
suponiendo que estás familiarizado con el tema,
probablemente hayas visto el método de eliminación
donde dices: "Bien, si de alguna manera puedo
sumar el lado izquierdo al lado izquierdo y el
lado derecho al lado derecho, las x se cancelarán
y al final me quedaré con las y, y ya hemos hecho
esto antes, es intentar despejar y", pero en este
video quiero que pensemos por qué terminas con un
sistema equivalente si fueras a hacer eso. Y una
forma de crear un sistema equivalente es mantener
mi primera ecuación 2x + y = 8, pero luego tomaré
mi segunda ecuación y sumaré lo mismo en ambos
lados. Sabemos que si sumas o restas lo mismo a
ambos lados de una ecuación obtienes una ecuación
equivalente, así que voy a hacer eso por aquí, va
a ser algo interesante. Si tienes 2x negativo -2
y = 10 negativo, y lo que quiero hacer es sumar 8
a ambos lados, puedo hacerlo así: sumar 8 en ambos
lados, pero recuerda que el sistema establece que
ambas afirmaciones son verdaderas, que 2 x + y = 8
y que 2x negativo - 2y = 10 negativo, entonces, en
lugar de sumar explícitamente 8 en ambos lados,
podría sumar algo que es equivalente a 8 en ambos
lados, y conozco algo que es equivalente a 8 con
base en esta primera ecuación. Puedo sumar 8 y
puedo sumar 8 en el lado izquierdo, o puedo sumar
2 x + y. Y ahora te pido que pauses el video y te
preguntes: ¿cómo puedo resolver esto?, ¿por qué me
dicen que estoy sumando lo mismo en ambos lados?
Porque recuerda que cuando tomamos un sistema,
suponemos que ambas ecuaciones tienen que ser
verdaderas. Un par xy satisface una ecuación
si y sólo si satisface a la otra. Entonces, aquí
sabemos que 2x + y debe ser igual a 8, por lo que,
si estoy sumando 2x + y a la izquierda y estoy
sumando 8 a la derecha, en realidad sólo estoy
sumando 8 en ambos lados, y esto preserva la
equivalencia, y cuando haces eso obtienes que
2x negativo y 2x se cancelan y queda y negativo
igual a 2 negativo; y así puedo reescribir esa
segunda ecuación como y negativa = 2 negativo. Y
sé lo que estás pensando: cuando resuelvo sistemas
de ecuaciones estoy acostumbrado a sumar estos
dos juntos y luego tengo esta ecuación, y esto
no es muy riguroso matemáticamente, porque la otra
ecuación sigue ahí, sigue siendo una restricción,
a menudo resuelves una y luego la sustituyes
en la otra, pero en realidad ambas ecuaciones
están ahí todo el tiempo, simplemente las estás
reescribiendo de manera equivalente. Entonces,
una vez más, este sistema, este sistema y este
sistema son equivalentes, cualquier par xy que
satisfaga a uno lo satisfará a todos y viceversa.
Y una vez más podemos seguir reescribiendo esto de
maneras equivalentes, puedo multiplicar ambos
lados de la segunda ecuación por 1 negativo,
eso es preservar la equivalencia, y si hago eso
obtengo 2x + y = 8, no he cambiado la ecuación
superior; y en la segunda ecuación, si multiplico
ambos lados por 1 negativo, obtengo que y = 2,
de nuevo todos estos son sistemas equivalentes. Sé
que suena muy repetitivo en esto, pero ahora puedo
hacer otra cosa para mantener la equivalencia
y al mismo tiempo tener una idea más clara de
cuál es este par xy. Si sabemos que y = 2 y sabemos
que esto se cumple en ambas ecuaciones, es decir,
se cumple en una y se cumple en la otra, y
suponemos que hay un par xy que satisface a
ambas ecuaciones, 2x + y = 8, y además y = 2, y
sabemos que esto se cumple en ambas ecuaciones.
Entonces quiere decir que cuando vemos una y aquí
arriba, podemos escribir un sistema equivalente en
donde en lugar de escribir y escribimos un
2, porque sabemos que y = 2, y así podemos
reescribir esta ecuación superior sustituyendo
2 en lugar de y, por lo que podemos reescribir
esto como: 2x + 2 = 8, y = 2. Aquí tenemos
que ambas se cumplen, y, por supuesto, podemos
seguir desarrollando esto. Voy a hacer un poco de
espacio. Puedo escribir otro sistema equivalente
a este haciendo operaciones que mantengan la
equivalencia de la ecuación superior. ¿Qué pasa
si resto 2 en ambos lados de la ecuación superior?
Todavía va a ser una ecuación equivalente y podría
reescribirla así, ya que si resto 2 en ambos lados
obtendré 2x = 6. Nota que esta segunda ecuación
no ha cambiado: y = 2, entonces hay un par xy
que si satisface a una satisface a la otra y
viceversa. Este sistema es equivalente a todos los
sistemas que he escrito hasta ahora en esta cadena
de operaciones, por así decirlo, y luego, para la
ecuación superior, una operación que mantiene la
equivalencia es dividir ambos lados entre un valor
distinto de 0, y en este caso podría dividir ambos
lados entre 2, si divido la parte superior
entre 2 queda x = 3 y y = 2. Y una vez más,
esta es una forma diferente de pensarlo: todo
lo que estoy haciendo es reescribir el mismo
sistema de manera equivalente, que nos sirva
para encontrar el par xy. En el pasado podrías
haber supuesto que podías sumar ambos lados de una
ecuación o hacer este tipo de eliminación o algún
tipo de sustitución para simplemente encontrar x y
y, pero realmente estás reescribiendo el sistema,
estás reescribiendo las restricciones
del sistema de maneras equivalentes
para ser explícito cuál es ese par xy que
satisface a ambas ecuaciones en el sistema.